i feel
free when i fly the balloon the feelings
the goosebumps that you get it's amazing
living in dubai gave me the opportunity
to do something that i love
you don't realize the real beauty of the
desert until you see it from above
[Music]
my name is mark beaumont and i'm an
endurance athlete
with the current world record for
cycling around the planet
seeking adventures and finding stories
is what i'm most passionate about
ever since i can remember i've had that
sense of curiosity about the world
this time i've come to dubai
when i travel to anywhere new it doesn't
matter where i am on planet earth i try
and get to the high point whether it's
the highest building or the mountain to
get perspective on where i am i love
that
i met with edgora a mom of two and in
training to become uae's first female
hot air balloon pilot to explore many of
the heights of dubai my name is edgora
i'm from uzbekistan and for the last 16
years i live here in dubai
i'm a hot air balloon pilot in training
a wife but most importantly i'm a mother
my daughter she's five now my son he's
three
and dubai is one of the best cities to
have children there's so much to do you
can entertain them every day different
stuff
after trying my first flight with
balloon adventures being in the basket
the balloon floating through the air and
observing the whole beauty of the flight
made me think okay this is what i want
to do and my interest quickly became my
passion
to be
first female hotel pilot in the uee
makes me feel very grateful and i hope i
can encourage other women to follow
their dreams
because that would make me feel very
honored
the feeling never changes each and every
time you take off you always feel like
wow
i always feel the goosebumps it's always
nice you never get used to that it's
just magical each and every time
when you're driving through the desert
it kind of looks quite samey but when
you when you fly above it it's
incredible how much
change there is especially at that first
light
when they turn the engines off you hear
nothing that's beautiful and you've just
got the view and that space and that
incredible horizon
i've got to see so much of dubai
during this trip but that's a different
perspective to fly over the desert is a
pretty extraordinary view it's unlike
anything i've done it's unique
being adventurous is about the want to
not just observe the world but the want
to to experience it to make your own
mind up think for yourself it's intrigue
it's interest it's it's wanting to do
things and explore and to ask the
questions
to be a hotel balloon pilot makes me
feel very proud very grateful from the
first time that i was in the balloon and
now
i feel that i have accomplished a lot
and i'm looking forward to get more and
more experience and to share my
my passion with others
[Music]
you